[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 178
over the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I'm muck and I'm here with muck
as well how you doing mark I'm mark I'm
also how are you mark
I'm very well mark how are you doing
Mike mark is doing great so I think I'll
call myself merch for now I know that
our accents are also very similar of
course we don't want people to get mixed
up yes yes yes but today we have a
christening from the Linux Foundation
CTO of CN CF and VP of devrel at the
Linux Foundation talking to us today all
about the Linux Foundation open-source
Foundation's open source stuff all good
things yeah it was a great conversation
that we had with him I you know I'd
heard of the Linux Foundation I think
most people have heard of Linux but
there's a lot of open source projects
out there and it turns out they can
sometimes be hard to manage yep so I
think it's really cool to hear what the
foundation does how it helps people out
and kind of like what that almost
governing body provides for all these
different communities yeah absolutely
and then I get to ask you a super
interesting question where I ask you how
do I connect cloud sequel to my server
list thing goes something very very
interesting and we'll have an answer for
you but before we get to that cool
things the week
all right what you got well first cool
thing of the week I'd like to call out a
blog post written by one of our very own
da's Felipe who wrote a very very cool
and interesting little cover of how do
you analyze rideshare data so we're here
in the Bay Area where traffic is
admittedly quite a disaster most of the
time yes and I think a lot of people are
always wondering how long it'll take and
it turns out Ober actually released some
public datasets including how long it
takes to get from certain destinations
to other certain destinations and then
Felipe who loves bigquery he does
decided to take all that put it together
and show off a cool little data studio
dashboard using the new BQ business
intelligence unit product yep that
basically makes it super quick to
analyze and do actual bi dashboards so
the medium post walks through kind of
how he did it it sets it up so you can
take a look at more than just the Bay
Area yep and it calls out that we have a
lot of cool public data sets for
bigquery so I think that's really
awesome that's cool awesome I have one
that I think is lots of fun mainly
because I like seeing machine learning
agents do very silly things
here's a contest going on over at Unity
called the obstacle tower challenge we
are a sponsor of the prizes which is
lovely but basically the first iteration
is now complete in which teams are
challenged to build an AI agent that has
to navigate a procedurally generated
obstacle course I can't navigate a
procedure absurd a general correct how
does me I gotta do it through AI oh good
point yeah pretty much
so this is really cool yes in the first
stage is a complete which I got the
details which will be in the blog post
and soon some teams are moving on to
round 2 that they've received more than
2,000 entries from several hundred teams
around the world very cool yeah it's a
good one to watch
speaking of bigquery before with
Felipe's blog post well there's actually
another cool blog post that came out a
little while ago that talked about big
queries GIS tools really and these are
things that you know are useful for
calculating distances kind of similar to
the public data share that uber had sent
out in this case it turns out that even
though we're talking about positions on
earth most of the time you can actually
take the same concepts and put them into
astronomy terms so now we're able to
look
huge public datasets of astronomy stuff
and then take that and say okay well
let's use the facing coordinates to
figure out where they are gather all
this big data right so now we've got all
the power of kind of doing rapid big
data analysis and comparing it to what
could possibly be the biggest data set
there is space space you know so I hear
people tell me I haven't quite seen all
of it myself
I tried seeing it once it took me anger
board is it it's not worth it this is
just a lot of black stone mark review
one out of ten so finally for me we have
another blog post gke sandbox bringing
defense-in-depth to your pods at cloud
next we announced the GK sandbox in beta
which is a new feature of GK e so if you
feel that you need an increased security
and isolation of your containers this
might be a nice thing for you it's based
on G Weiser
the open source container sandbox
runtime basically if you're running
anything that potentially maybe is like
slightly untrusted like someone's
providing you user code are you running
a multi-tenancy environment you might
want to try this out it's pretty cool
we'll link to it in the blog post but
basically with a couple of extra
annotations on your pod and a new type
of thing inside your node pool you're
pretty much good to go and then you can
just continue running as you were before
with just that extra layer of security
it's pretty sweet I think we're seeing a
lot of kind of cool customizations that
you can have now because you know
there's one thing to be said about
kubernetes and then actually having a
managed kubernetes but now it's like how
many little buttons and bells and
whistles can I start get on there yeah
this is another one in the latest line
wonderful I think that's everything yeah
well one more last one not least okay
you have a quick announcement for a
great new public data center that just
got launched very true over in Japan I
believe in Osaka yep so that brings us
to what twenty regions worldwide that's
a lot it's nice to see right so people
can kind of choose when they're gonna
launch their services where they want it
make sure they can kind of get that
closest to the user as possible always a
good thing to have yep and additional
regions are coming soon with Seoul Salt
Lake City and Jakarta coming in the
first half of 2020 very very cool and
not that far off now well why don't we
go have a chat with Chris about all the
open-source things the Linux Foundation
sounds good
[Music]
okay so super excited we have my dear
buddy Chris and nice chick here joining
us at cloud next CTO of CN CF and VP of
dev rel at the Linux Foundation how you
doing today Chris oh pretty good it's
nice to be in this small little house
that we have here for the podcast yes
listeners can't see it but is an
adorable little house it's adorable it's
comfy
yeah Hosie ask me feel at home yeah
actually does your house look like a
giant yellow Plexiglas building yeah I
mean well if I moved it took a while but
you know San Francisco rental prices
before we get too ridiculous do you
wanna tell us a little bit about who you
are what you do like CN CF Linux
Foundation yeah sure I mean I basically
have two roles you know I serve as VP of
Deverell at all of winning foundation
what basically means if people aren't
familiar with the Linux Foundation it's
really not only about Linux anymore we
kind of are a family of foundations
right we have things like the node.js
foundation or I guess it's the Open GL
foundation there's CN CF which I helped
start
there's the automotive Linux Foundation
and so on so I helped basically run
devrel for across all these different
foundations and make sure those
communities of developers are very happy
in those respective communities but most
of my day job these days is focused on
really taking care of the CNC F
technical community as CTO so working
with our independent technical board to
make sure you know we're accepting
wonderful projects into the community
and also making sure in general our
projects and developers are super happy
with the services that the foundation
provides now that makes a lot of sense
to me
except for one part yeah you listed a
lot of foundations there yeah and a lot
of different teams yeah let's start the
highest level yeah what is the purpose
of the Linux Foundation cool very simple
so if you like go pull up like the
bylaws and charter the Linux Foundation
is basically tasked to support and
sustain the development of Linux yep and
open source software and that open
source software is very broad so
initially Linux Foundation started out
very focused on Linux like Linus and
Greg H the stable and stable maintainer
x' are employed as fellows and go hack
on the kernel and make sure to take care
of it but eventually what happened as
you know Linux grew and just general
open source grew people were trying to
find ways to kind of collaborate and if
you kind of look at it there's a lot of
different you know foundations out there
there's a patch
but they're kind of motto is very much
focused on the individual and they kind
of pretend companies don't exist is very
it's all it's very individual community
and their volunteer run so there's no
necessary services the Linux Foundation
is more of a professional services kind
of Foundation where we shake people on
staff that help with marketing Deverell
you know technical writing all the stuff
that like generally project maintainers
don't like to do but are super useful
for building community running events
we're getting on coop con Barcelona in
month a half soon and you know it's an
almost a ten thousand person event
that's a lot to put on but actually
super useful to build community so we
are kind of a full-service professional
staff organization we've grown to
support open source in all different
industries people would come to us and
say like you know teairra hey we want to
do something in the automotive industry
to bring open-source to cars to make
things you know more efficient
innovative we've worked at the telco
industry so we have Linux Foundation
networking we cleaned up the mess with
the night o gs 4head emerge those things
into one organization so we've kind of
just grown through Linux was one of the
early open-source projects and people
naturally came to our organization for
help so you said I mean you've said
support and then you've also listed like
a wide variety of very interesting
things that you do for open source
projects as a whole is there any limit
to that like how does that get cool like
what happened yeah so I mean think about
each kind of sub foundation it kind of
runs independently right they have their
own you could kind of think of like a
business unit there's an P&L and
potentially own staff but the parent
entity is the Linux Foundation so they
kind of basically work with the
community figure out what what they
needs you know I kind of is saying that
each open-source project is unhappy in
their own unique way and you kind of
have to work with them to figure out
maybe you need infrastructure help you
know a lot of the kind of the telco
focused foundations they have like
physical devices like routers and other
crazy stuff and so you kind of need a
lab to kind of help them with others may
just need help with you know we don't
like technical writing we kind of suck
at it can you help us with that so we do
kind of a variety things based on you
know each you know type of project but
the elif's a fairly decently large
organization like we also host things
like people forget let's encrypt org you
know everyone loves free SSL certs you
know we basically bootstrap that and you
know sustain it essentially as an
organization so I mean that's still a
long list of things that you do yeah but
it's really interesting when you
mentioned that groups are open source
groups will come to you and say we need
some help doing
yep how does that group okay with
working with like hey let's just sign
everything over to this foundation yeah
so I mean think about it businesses
inherently don't trust each other right
in many ways right they feel like oh
you're gonna sue me for something or
like you know less there's some type of
agreement or partnership well by putting
code and some level of IP whether it's
you know a trademark in a neutral place
like we did with kubernetes we have this
wonderful conformance program that
everyone have you know works with and
ensures that they respect the project
and our conformant we set these types of
things up before different organizations
for different industries verticals and
projects so having a neutral entity and
the IP owned in a neutral way builds
trust across these companies and they
decide together what they want to work
on together like what part of the
industry maybe is commoditize that's
some layer or some interesting thing
they kind of want to chasten and work on
together so essentially neutrality
builds trust and to me is a cornerstone
at working together so say you handle
intercompany politics really well it's a
I will tell you the sad thing about this
job it unfortunately makes you respect
politicians a little bit more and that's
painful well I mean highlights right
like I'm sure there are and there has
been no shortage of and probably
currently are plenty of conflicts
between different people wanting to go
different ways different incentives and
different people in the community who
are just like I don't know if I want to
be governed by some higher authority
that I didn't choose yeah or they
compete at the market at some level and
someone's like I want to go push this
feature into something that I may sell
but you know at the end of day like we
very much focus on open source projects
and making sure they are very healthy
sustained and do everything to make sure
they're healthy our members build
products that compete in the market and
go fight it out and figure out what they
do and so like we just our whole goal we
kind of have the saying of projects
products profits so we sustain projects
our members build products sell them
make them up profits and that gets
funneled back into the foundation how do
people get involved you know if I've got
a little project where I'm like hey I
read a little like go library and I want
to put that in the Linux Foundation I'm
assuming that's not something I can do
you know there there is a process if you
actually go to the Linux Foundation org
website there's like propose a project
and there's kind of like a little forum
but you know recently we announced an
initiative called the community bridge
door gates so if you know maybe you
don't need a full-blown crazy foundation
but you may want to have support to
maybe raise a little funding for like a
meet-up or an event
or you may want to do internships so we
kind of even have like a quote-unquote
summer code as a service for a lack of a
better analogy that could go all
year-round so we have that available for
people that are just individual projects
it may not have like crazy backing or
something yeah so I know recently I
believe you formed a coalition or
whatever you want to call it for the
Media Association or something the only
you can make software foundation for
when I'm looking for the film industry
which they don't love to collaborate
either but they've decided you know what
maybe we should start not reinventing
all these like color tools and other
things and you know let's collaborate on
the basis because what we're actually
good at stories and making movies not
actually the sulfur Tamiya hose now how
long did that take what was that process
two plus years you know generally when
these things start they don't happen
overnight usually one person that you
know once a champion open source and
organization has realized like this is
stupid we're reinventing the wheel all
over the place comes to us or somehow we
run into them at an event and we just
start to discussions you know the Linux
Foundation has over a thousand members
worldwide and so we just like reach out
oh we know this person here and then we
kind of may be hosting a little vent or
meetup and naturally people come
together and write a mission vision and
you know maybe a foundation is formed or
maybe it isn't so sometimes it doesn't
work out yeah I mean that's not unique
to the media there's a lot of industries
that still prefer very private kind of
closed-door not open conversations we're
actually seeing other industries like
pharma they don't really like to talk to
each other much either and they're
starting to dabble potentially in open
source and so we're just like into this
area where you know we're one of the
early pioneers of open source as an
organization and we essentially act as
foundation as a service and bring
communities together that want to
collaborate on some specific piece of
software
what's the sell there I mean you're not
selling anything cuz ultimately they're
not paying right but like how do you go
to encroach these people or do they just
come to but just naturally come to us
generally so there's no like proactive
reach out it's usually the the problems
are actually coming from the businesses
or people that have them so we're not
actively going out so you should do open
source open source is great what sort of
problems do you think they're trying to
solve with open source cross company
collaborations so generally there's some
piece of the stack that they may want to
commoditize just like the Academy
Software Foundation all these like color
tools that you know they've come up with
they were reinventing on their own in
there
but he policies did not allow them to
easily collaborate you know with
different organizations so if you put
the code in a foundation there's usually
an IP policy that everyone agrees to a
fair governance policy that everyone
agrees to of how maintainer czar elected
and removed and then all the sudden the
companies could collaborate
yep together in a fair way it's like a
sports match or something where you know
everyone knows how the rules of hockey
work and there's a referee or something
so let's let's go out it do you also
work in the other way where it like you
may go into companies and educate them
about open source and like how they can
work in that arena in a better way
100% half my job is probably educating
companies that are new to open source or
don't understand how it works it's
actually my personal vision of like open
source is sustained by convincing
companies that I open source is a good
thing that they should contribute to
either by hiring maintainer x' or
contributing to two projects and just
being involved in the communities and we
tend to live a little bit in a bubble
sometimes and kind of like the Silicon
Valley area and but if you go out to
automotive companies or pharma companies
they haven't heard of criminais days you
know bless their heart but like opens
can't open sources new to them and so we
do a lot of education we have free
resources guides that we produce I
co-founded one initiative called the two
new group that or agrees to run the open
source office at Twitter where we just
produced a bunch of material of like how
to contribute to open source how to
start a project how to work with others
you know what happens when things go
wrong and open sores and so we just open
sourced all these things available for
companies to learn from and use yeah I
know I've definitely run into companies
where I know members who would just be
like I can't even write feedback on a
github project because like legal or PR
it's not gonna you have to go through
the 11 circles of you know legal and PR
effort oh yeah every chat every time for
a patch or for everything up but I think
you do some legal services as well as I
do we have legal staff and an external
counsel on trademarks and just legal
device at all like the Linux Foundation
bye
you join the organization there's
actually a legal network and they have I
think conferences twice a year where all
these lawyers go into room which I want
to avoid but that you know they talk to
each other and they learn from each
other it's just kind of one benefit of
being part of the organization it's a
usually huge function of what we do is
education of how open-source works you
know actually that's an interesting
point people can still be part of the
foundation but they don't necessarily
have to open source code they may just
be there so that they can interact with
open source
yeah absolutely I mean all our projects
don't require any form of membership or
like like all technical stuff you just
show up and contribute you know it's a
democracy essentially like if you show
up maybe you'll become a maintainer or
something the funding there is just to
sustain us like it's not cheap to put on
Cube Khan you know it's you know or
technical writers and so on so that's
kind of where the resources go to
sustain them so that's a pretty helpful
overview of why the Linux Foundation is
important and some of the reasons that a
lot of people look at some of the
projects there but you mentioned that
you've been spending a lot of time on
CNCs yeah I was employee one start with
CNCs and the open container initiative
at the same time which if you remember
you know a wonderful container wars of
days old so yeah are we settled on that
is that good like Oh see I we have
containers that we have an image spec we
have a runtime spec that team is
actively working on a distribution spec
so oh my god it wouldn't be amazing if
registries had the same kind of API out
there yeah there wasn't any crazy issues
where one didn't support multi org
support or something
so they are like working together on
those problems and they've made a lot of
progress almost every container runtime
supports the OCI image and runtime spec
got something to say you were like
number one at CN CF where did that come
from what was the need no it's kind of
interesting story is you know I spent
five years before joining Linux
Foundation and Twitter working on open
source infrastructure so we had our
containers maysa before they were really
cool I quit that job after five years of
startup good times learned a lot and
then I was living in the valley yeah
exactly exactly I think I need a little
time off after that and then I had this
wonderful conversation with the head of
the Linux Foundation Jim's m1 to call me
is like you know Google has you know
open source kubernetes you know there's
a bunch of folks that want to kind of
build a standard round container if you
want to come help this you have a lot of
experience at open source and so on it's
great you know we're nonprofit it's
gonna be super easy just come do this
and you know so I asked Oliva vacation
not for profit like you get like 30
vacations there's something sweet great
you turned out to be is super I don't
say painful but very rewarding like you
know it bringing together challenging is
probably a better word but bringing
together competitors to like century
collaborate and decide which parts of
the stack essentially we actually want
to commoditize or agree that we should
standardize is a fun experiment and it
shows kind of the values I don't think
if we did not do OCI and help grow
whereas today it wouldn't have worked
out without getting that agreement on
you know container formats and so on
otherwise like if you go to a different
cloud you'd have to go like rebuild your
containers or use another format it
would be a nightmare yeah I mean I think
that's a very valuable point to why
these things exists again going back to
why these foundations are kind of yeah
and I think the other useful thing is
like I do want to say like when you know
Craig McKee luckily and sunny you know
Sarah Nevada and some of the other folks
that were very early involved with the
foundation is we made a deliberate
decision not to just call it like the
kubernetes foundation it was going to be
the cloud native computing foundation to
encompass more than just one specific
project you know or technology it was
like to come up with a kind of here's
our mission we want to spread cloud
native bring projects together that are
very useful in the space we don't
necessarily want to anoint one
technically project is a winner would
you kind of want to build some
specifications and it worked out pretty
well I think we're a lot more successful
with that mission than just specifically
saying or just the kubernetes foundation
so so you were employee number one yeah
yeah
what does cloud native mean to you oh my
gosh we ask the hard questions on this
mug I know it's great so you know it's
kind of funny is you know when we
started the organization it was like
cloud native is all about services that
live in containers that are orchestrated
by some central process and that was
kind of like the originally thing that
was baked into the Charter but recently
we had this funny debate within the CN
CF Technical Community of maybe we
should write down the definition or
update it and so it's actually been
updated it's on github it's actually
much longer than I like but essentially
encompasses that original definition but
it includes more things like service
meshes concept resiliency and so on so I
if I had my computer for me I go read it
but that's it it is too long but it is
something that the community of you know
we have hundreds of members thousands of
Delta pavelic's kindred that actually
came up greed upon and voted on it it's
translated into like Chinese Japanese
Korean on get up is that gonna continue
to grow though I mean especially as the
ecosystem kind of rapidly is right now
exploding in every direction yeah how is
the foundation gonna be able to kind of
oversee a good chunk of that we're no
longer one person anymore there's a
staff about yeah exactly there's a staff
about 30 or so folks that work directly
on CNCs full-time we have a lovely booth
here I don't know if you swung by
alright that yeah exactly it's very
pretty with lots of stickers so if
you're into like you know fluent D you
know container de
I have a few sneakers away I saw some
podcast stickers that somehow ended up
on the exactly we have a decent amount
of staff now so we have about a little
over 30 projects now and you know as we
grow as an organization we try to staff
up appropriately and part of our work is
not only you know staffing the
foundation but also working with
companies to convince them that you know
if you're betting your business on
kubernetes you know maybe you should try
to contribute some resources to
translate the Agra Nettie's Docs into
Japanese or you know contribute in your
own way and a lot of companies actually
need that you know education because
they're you know very new to open-source
you know it's it's very surprising if
you're just living in the bay and
sometimes you go talk to a bunch of
crazy customers or you know people that
are new to open-source there's there's
lots of them we're still kind of in the
early days of people understanding open
source in my opinion yeah I mean it's
not I mean it's not necessarily crazy
it's just different people at different
levels of the stackin and that's just
where they're at and that that makes
sense right now so I mean that sounds
good from like you can join this
foundation you can get the support if
you don't like it you don't join very
simple or you could still always
contribute code like if you want to
fiscally support it you're more than
welcome to but it's not a requirement by
any means but if you're building like
kubernetes conformant type things and
yeah maybe you should support this
organization because you're betting your
business on it have you run into any
people who are actually like resisting
the foundation
it's more of an education like so like
what do you necessarily do or it's like
I have this like kubernetes distribution
oh there's a conformance program oh it's
run by CN CF I had no idea that you know
this existed so it's more of just
educating people and kind of what we do
we produce these kind of amazing annual
reports I don't know if you've seen them
yet but if you go to CN CF website go
down there find the latest annual report
kind of shows like the amount of events
we put on the amount of like you know
diversity scholarships that we've done
an organization amount of contributions
we've done as an organization so we kind
of just published all that and try to
educate people out there kind of what
the organization does and how they could
kind of get involved nice sounds like
there's a lot of stuff that happens at
the organizational level if I'm just a
lone developer talking away in my cube
what have you done for me lately like
what what is the CNC AFM the Linux
Foundation kind of do with the
individual layer or is it just more like
I'm helping you build stuff and that's
it's a combination everything on an
individual level it's like we've given
out I think last year three
hundred-plus diversity scholarships you
know if you're an individual coming from
wherever and like hey I want to attend
my first you know cube con so we've done
a lot of that like it's hard like from a
Linux Foundation perspective it's like a
minute let's encrypt or do the free
Assessor that's very exactly with the
community bridge platform that we
launched now we offer like summer code
as a service anytime for projects and so
you go have an internship any time of
the year instead of just a specific time
so I think it's a politician we have
multiple constituents right we have
members we have individuals developers
and so we try to provide services for
all different types of you know
constituents because they have different
carers and needs you know back to my
saying like each open-source project is
unhappy in their own unique way and we
do our best to kind of work with
different you know types of people
companies and so on to address your
needs what interesting trends are you
seeing at the moment across open-source
you seeing anything that's like changing
the landscape over time you know I don't
want to talk about the whole like
open-source licensing gate you know
stuff going on with companies you know
coming up with kind of bespoke anti-type
will take cloud licenses I think it's
just a long topic but the thing that I
see the most is new industries that you
would not think would have anything to
do with open-source you know the
automotive industry the pharma industry
cities even are starting to want to
collaborate and even share data amongst
each other so a lot of trend of like new
industries that you typically would not
expect to do anything with open-source
are starting to realize that we would
like to collaborate potentially with
each other and we kind of want a fair a
neutral place to do that so we're
getting approached a lot by these new
industries even like the gaming industry
giving back to our original meeting at
GDC what it what has been the
particularly challenging thing that
you've been working on because I know
I'm guessing there's a lot I mean
working with varying interests and
various incentives I mean I think it's
sometimes difficult you know as an
organization we are still somewhat of a
small amount for profits so we are kind
of limited in resources in some ways
when we kind of start new things so you
know recently I was working with
Facebook on a project at the op
Technology core graph QL solves a very
interesting problem and they was a large
community of folks out there that wanted
to see graph QL in a neutral place right
you know and so it was a year-plus
project to kind of make that happen you
know convince the right parties work
with lawyers and eventually that was
kind of done as like a side project yeah
and now that the Foundation's finally
kind of formed that could be properly
staffed
we kind of have this weird like
bootstrapping problem where like you
know someone will come to us with an
idea and you know let's just work on
this on my side and figure out what you
know eventually I'll make it work and
then you know we'll get it staffed
appropriately so it's kind of a we have
a bit of a resource you know constraint
type problem when it comes with new
projects because we are kind of fairly
small compared to you know these
wonderful billion dollar companies all
around so what's on your wish list I
mean I'm like what are you really hoping
to see soon like I said my focus is CN
CF like keeping our projects you know
happy avoiding conflict as much as
possible and making sure that we
continue to grow like diversity in our
community you know infrastructure as a
space tends to just not be as diverse as
other parts of software in my opinion so
we do our best to ensure that we had
tons of diversity scholarships for a lot
of our Q con related events and I mean
last year I think we threw over $300,000
last year in diversity scholarship which
is the most of any open source
foundation and to continue to grow that
to make sure our community is inclusive
and diverse I think is super important
and something that I'm personally
passionate about at the Linux Foundation
and CNC F so if I'm either a company or
an individual and I want to get involved
either with a Linux foundation or CNC F
like where should they go what should
they do I mean generally most people get
involved at the project level it's like
oh I use graph QL I'm gonna go
contribute that or you know I use
spinnaker I'm gonna go find that and the
most of the times a lot of these
projects are just project first and they
just happen to live in a foundation that
kind of holds the you know trademark or
IP or you know whatever so just go to
the projects that you normally
contribute to you know you may be
surprised that they're part of one
station you have no specific idea those
probably people who work on this stuff
and have no idea what the foundation
does or anything of that nature yeah we
do our best to try to message but you
know our whole you know philosophy is to
let the project's do what they're good
at and try to stay out of the way we
don't like force crazy governance or
anything we're just basically kind of
like referees and neutral holders of IP
to ensure people behave essentially it's
kind of imagine like a sports match it
wouldn't be fun if you were playing in
kind of a game and you know one team had
an advantage or over another or
something and the referee wasn't really
doing their job and so we try to make
sure the rules are fair and and these
organizations are supported from a
company or even like a group of people
who are like oh I think we have a great
project that would be a great fit
somewhere
you go to linux foundation org you know
projects I think there's like close to
project is Nina link go check it out
there you know last year we hosted
events that probably nearly had thirty
five or forty thousand people go to open
source summit you know we're doing one
in August in San Diego let's go to cube
con we host a lot of different events
out there so that's one way to kind of
get involved with the community but go
to the website we have a lot of
information cool before we finish up is
there anything we haven't covered
something you want to make sure that the
listeners know about before we get done
no I mean a lot of times you know the
simple thing is people get confused at
like the Linux Foundation obviously
Linux is a big part of it but we do a
lot more than that you know a lot of
people don't realize we support let's
encrypt org we fix the node io GS you
know things now that's actually open to
us so now the node.js foundation and the
JSF / jQuery folks all merge into one
happy entities so just that we do a lot
more than I think people realize and so
check out our website and kind of go to
our projects page and you'll be
surprised what's actually on there have
you considered the tag line more than
just oh I lost that war like maybe we
should rename the foundation and then we
just get some stickers I think Linux
Foundation more than just Linux yeah
exactly
ya know every time you get a free SSL
cert you know send a little love to
Linux Foundation we help make that
happen well thank you very much for that
conversation it's been fun Jason yeah so
that was a great conversation with Chris
obviously thanks so much Chris for
coming in super super cool to hear I
didn't know much about all these
open-source foundations and you know
kind of why they were so important in
the world and obviously with all these
different people kind of working
together I can see why they might need a
little bit of support from the higher
layer absolutely definitely love that
well let's get stuck into the question
of the week
what I want to know is if I've got cloud
sequel how do I connect that to my
syphilis thing goes well that's the
technical term by the way fingers the
thing goes yeah see here at Google we
have lots of thing goes pretty well if
you're not using thing goes but instead
you're using something like oh I don't
know the recently announced cloud run
pretty good offering I think for most
people it turns out it's becoming a lot
easier to connecting these things so
it's additionally you might have
something like you know opening up your
sequel to public IP address which is a
fantastic idea and everyone should do it
across yeah clearly you know there's a
lot of security implications with
opening up a database to the outside
world so oftentimes people don't want to
do that so in the case of clarin or in
the case of service offerings it can be
kind of tricky to understand well you
can't just white list a few IPS or
something like that it's it's not as
easy to connect well thankfully there's
a cool blog post where cloud run talks
about some recent additions they've made
since the kind of the next open beta for
everybody to try out and one of them is
just a very really quick command-line
argument you post in called add cloud
sequel instances no nest couldn't be
much easier so if you're running cloud
run on the kind of just hosted version
which is all the server lists then you
can kind of just add in that command
line you pass it to your cloud sequel
instance and you're good to go if you're
running cloud run on kubernetes so you
have a little bit more structure and
that's kind of the the Kay native aspect
of it then it's actually pretty easy to
follow a different set of instructions
but you're adding a proxy in front of
cloud sequel so you take that proxy you
connect to that instead and you still
kind of maintain your private cloud
sequel so all the details are in the
blog post it's actually two lines I
think if you want to add it to cloud run
so super super easy and I think that
that'll open up a lot more access for
people to run databases along with the
serverless apps nice very very cool all
right well before we wrap up today mark
what are you up to what are you doing
what cool things you're doing well I'm
working on a lot of video projects so
hoping to come out and view some
customers on the East Coast soon and
just in general you know I try to live
my life without moving as much as
possible as possible no I'm waving no
leg shaking so far so good I'm hoping to
record the podcast from my decks
desk next time nice that would be not
recorded from my bed
they see actually that's good you'd have
like really good audio quality because
it's probably quite absorbent I hadn't
actually thought about that but now
you're actually like let me put a
document together there he goes
yeah anyway cool all right whatever I up
to looks like I'll be speaking it next
to Tokyo in July so if you're in the
region please come by say hello August I
will be at the open source in gaming day
which is right before the open source
North America summit I may or may not be
speaking I have a CF PN but I'm on
committee so who knows I don't know you
vote for yourself in the committee I
cannot vote for myself now you know what
that makes a lot of it doesn't it well
there was some kind of foundation to
tell people how to run these oh wait we
just talked about that yep exactly it's
exactly the foundation that is running
the open source North America summit
could tie in good time thank you
excellent all right fantastic well I
think that wraps everything up well mark
good to chat with you you too thank you
for joining me on this episode of the
podcast we'll see you all next week see
you all next week
[Music]